what are five things a director should
never do on set
not know the story so like
not understand the scene completely so
when an actor asks a question they're
like oh
i don't know like um uh
not put an actor under pressure um
because of the
time constraints of production to get
a performance obviously you know that
you will need to get the shot in a
certain time but i think by like
not letting the actor be aware of like
this
the set and the um like the time
constraints is really helpful because
you're not
i think without the pressure that
they'll give a better performance and to
try and keep that separate so um
i think that's why the director really
is the only person who talks to the
actors
uh they're not talk they're not like in
the conversations with the camera person
and all the like the camera person would
talk to the director they kind of keep
it all the way
so that they can just concentrate on the
performance
i think not
i think a director has to care about the
movie like so not caring about it so
um you know when you're on a set and you
can tell that the director
is not particularly or they're like
doing it for money
um and they're not really into the story
i think it shows
so think of the director you pick on
every production should really like
care about the story or be really
excited and want to do it
um i think that's really important
but i like what you said just real
quickly about like protecting them so is
it almost like
protecting a child from like knowing
certain news
so then the actor is going to be
protected while it's on set
yeah so they don't like have to worry
about anything but the character because
um that was one thing um with like
producing the honeymoon phase like close
to
um actually filming i was
not doing as much producing work as i
was just doing the acting
so that i wasn't like oh my gosh you
know we have to do this for tomorrow and
this
on set as i was acting and worrying
about that too much so it's kind of just
like
just letting the actor do their thing
and not have them outside worries is so
important because i think that they will
deliver better performance
because they're not pressured they're
not worried about other things like
their mind is only on the character um
for me that's like huge uh so i if i
direct and i've only directed like
little shots
um but i tried to do that
still shorts or something i mean they
that'll add up
you know and then do you think you'll
ever
do a feature in the next let's say four
years
direct a picture uh i thought about it
eventually
um i don't i don't know if i would
direct i like directing but i don't like
it's so stressful i feel too direct
because you
are the core person on that production
um that
everyone looks to for everything
um and i think if it was like a really
cool
horror story of a direct um but i'd have
to be like
really into it um to feel like i would
do it justice
as the director yeah maybe i guess
but i prefer acting and producing
they're my two favorite things
you